une théière qui devient locomotive des
cafetières qui font des courses
hippiques
jérôme bailly détourne les objets du
quotidien il leur a vendu notre vie pour
nous embarquer dans sa rêverie un monde
décalé entre fantastique fantaisie et
poésie
j'aime détourné parce que j'aime pas
voir le monde
c'est pas que j'aime pas voir le monde
tel qu'il est mais j'ai toujours besoin
et envie de faire un petit pas de côté
j'ai pas forcément envie de représenter
dans mes tableaux la réalité telle
qu'elle est voilà donc je joue c'est
c'est la raison pour laquelle je joue
avec le décalage
vraiment c'est pour ce petit pas de côté
depuis plus d'un an à cause de la crise
sanitaire les artistes ne peuvent pas
faire d'exposition pour vendre leurs
toiles jérôme bailly a donc mis ses
peintures sur internet bien obligée pour
montrer son travail rien ne vaut de voir
une toile en vrai mais le fait est que
la situation actuelle nous force à la
fin nous oblige à passer par internet et
ça offre une possibilité une visibilité
énorme du coup mes étoiles voyage dans
le monde entier
ça c'est pas ton
si vous souhaitez voir les peintures de
l'artiste et échanger avec lui il ouvre
les portes de son atelier sur rendez
vous jusqu'au 25 avril